il est minuit passé de 9 minutes nous
sommes en direct sur Public Sénat pour
suivre ce scrutin public sur l'ensemble
de l'article 7 mesures phare mesure
centrale du projet de loi de réforme des
retraites voulu par l'exécutif une
accélération ces dernières minutes pour
arriver au vote sur l'ensemble de ce
texte et sans surprise la majorité de la
droite et du centre qui devrait adopter
cette mesure dans les prochaines minutes
et aussi donc une défaite pour la gauche
sénatoriale qui aura tenté des dépôts
d'amendement des explications de vote ou
encore des scrutins publiques pour
ralentir cette échéance mais la droite
qui va réussir à parvenir à faire voter
cette mesure dans les prochaines minutes
inscrit un public donc on va voir
l'ensemble de la cartographie du vote à
l'échelle de l'hémicycle on va pouvoir
voir s'il y a par exemple des sénateurs
LR ou centrist qui manquent à l'appel
dans ce scrutin solennelle de l'ensemble
de l'hémicycle on va voir sans surprise
en revanche que elle est 90 sénateurs de
gauche vont voter contre cet article
article 7 donc qui décale de 62 à 64 ans
l'âge de départ à la retraite et qui
accélère la réforme Touraine
effectivement et les 43 annuités vous
êtes en train de vivre ce vote en direct
sur public Sénart on va écouter Gérard
lacher prononcer les résultats de ce
scrutin public
316 pour 201 contre 115 le Sénat a
adopté l'article 7
[Applaudissements]
nous allons passer
[Musique]